-Jokic is unstoppable!
-Duncan, take the shot.
-I missed so badly! Aaah
-Are we done? I miss my horses.
-Mid-range dagger!
-No look hammer!
-All... those... 3am chin-ups... led me to this.
Gasp
-You're tired, now you can rest.
-AHHHHHHHHHH!
-[Radio]: Dame to Miami is a sure thing.
We’ve got all the leverage.
Pat Riley’s got nine rings for a reason.
-This is the story of how we followed up a disappointing finals…
-You wanted to see me, Godfather?
-Yes, Jimmy.
…with an even worse off-season.
-We need another hero. Another alpha.
-But Boss, I'm the alpha.
-We'll just work harder this year. That's Heat Culture.
-I'M PAT F***ING RILEY. I AM HEAT CULTURE.
-This is a tale of hubris, greed….
and tragedy.
-Here's his coordinates. Get him.
-Why doesn't he come here?
-The city won’t let him leave.
-This is how the Heat flamed out in Portland.
-What kind of hippie bullshit is this?
-Jimmy!
-Oh, you gotta try OUR coffee.
-Have you met Scoot?
-Huh?!
-Damn, Dame. You DO need help.
-Thanks.
♪ Wow, Portland. How do I begin to fix this? ♪
♪ I’m so close to being heated, but this is a business ♪
♪ I gotta Scoot away, I’m sorry for the-
-Sorry?
-Does that "sorry" come with a first round pick?!
-I forgive you.
-Calm down. You also get...
-Tyler Herro!
-Damn, son. I guess there ain’t no friends in this business.
It is what it is, feel me?
-We're not idiots!
What ever happened to loyalty?
You have roots here!
-Don't go Dame Time. I'm the dog here. I'll get us out.
-Look, we're building around you!
Isn't that what you wanted?
-Don't expect me to stand in the corner and wait for my shot.
-Hahaha, GUILT TRIP!
-I just bought your jersey!
-I named my dog after you!
-I moved here for you!
-Now we want to hold onto Dame...even...more!
-I can run all day...
but I think it's time to blow up another small market.
-But that's... way too intense.
-No, that's just Jimmy.
Why is this so difficult!
-Hey. Someone left all these bombs around.
Sorry I'm late. I had to fend off the raptors.
-Giannis?!
-No no no, I can’t let you go with him!
-You think you can come in here all cocky, offer no sacrifice...
...and threaten to blow us up?!
The Bucks respected us!
They offered us a fair package.
They never demanded anything from us.
So take him, Giannis. He's yours.
-Oh, wow, the Cream City Dojo is now stacked!
Maybe I will stay.
-Sorry, Jimmy.
But now we both know we're ready for a partner.
Thanks.
-We got played!!!!
-[Radio]: I mean, Pat Riley’s only got 9 rings...
Guy’s gotta go.
-Ooh hell yeah, this joint slaps.